8:25 and Wessex is victorious at the
Battle of Ellington ending the mercy and
supremacy this victory was quickly
followed by Wessex annexing all of these
southern kingdoms all of this occurred
under the rule of King edge burr who had
previously been exiled to frankerq by
the Mersey and King offer after offers
deaf edge but returned to Wessex
probably with the help of Charlemagne
him was crowned king in 802 his reign
was one of Wessex his most successful
four years after his victory edgemon
invaded Mercer and managed to force the
Mersenne King Wiglaf into exile soon
afterwards he invaded Northumbria and
received the submission of his King edge
but is thus considered to be an overlord
of Britain at this point but like most
things it didn't last because by 830
mercy had revolted against him Mircea
couldn't pry the southern kingdoms from
Wessex in East Anglia became an
independent Kingdom again ed Bert's
later rule did contain further setbacks
though for example in 835 Kemp was
heavily plundered by Vikings and the
next year he was defeated by the Danes
here
however in 838 he did win a victory over
them and their dumb Nonie and allies
attacks by Vikings who were commonly
referred to in sources as Danes
increased dramatically over the
following decades the majority of the
Vikings who attacked the anglo-saxons
during this period were from Denmark
hence Danes some were from modern-day
Norway though and those Vikings were
referred to as Norse quick fact the term
Viking actually comes from the Old
English term Bikaner which means pirate
so the increase in activity culminated
in the 865 great heathen army which
landed here in East Anglia the
difference with the great heathen army
called so because the Vikings were
pagans and the previous raiding parties
was that now the Vikings are in Britain
for conquest within four years of their
landing east angler and Northumbria had
been defeated east anglia was hence
ruled by Danes and Northumbria was split
in half the northern half remaining
under the rule of the angles
Wessex at this point was ruled by King
Ethelred the fourth eldest son of Etha
wolf Eggbert successor in 870 the great
heathen army camped at Redding here
before invading Wessex Ethelred was
victorious against the Danes inflicting
upon them their first defeat the Danes
bounced back in in 871 defeated the West
Saxon forces at the Battle of hazing
roughly here to make things worse King
Ethelred died and was succeeded by his
brother Alfred better known nowadays as
Alfred the Great
Etha red actually had a son called ëthe
award but alfred was chosen to be king
instead this is because the crown did
not necessarily pass from father to
eldest son in Wessex the wit and the
King's Advisory Council made up of high
ranking Nobles was involved in the
succession
most of the time they simply rubber
stamped the Kings
to dare who was often the oldest son
alfred was chosen over a ward because
there the wood was still a child at this
point and the situation with the vikings
requires stability the fact that Wessex
could appoint Kings without having to
suffer a civil war each time was one of
the reasons it stood as firmly as it did
one thing that ought to be remembered is
that the anglo-saxons and the Danes were
not mortal enemies that could never
coexist and rival claimants to a throne
could and did enlist vikings for support
alfred began his reign by bravely paying
the vikings to leave thus the great
heathen army went north to pillage
mercier before splitting in half one
half went north to settle Northumbria
and the other led by a man called goofer
and went south back to Wessex in 876 the
Viking didn't really do much in in 877
they split up again to divide mercier
leaving an even smaller force under
Goodrem which launched a surprise attack
into Wessex the next year alfred was
forced to flee to Athenee in the marshes
of somerset which is here he waited
there as his forces were mustered across
Wessex and after assembling they fought
the Danes at the Battle of Eddington
this was a decisive victory for Alfred
the subsequent peace treaty between
Alfred and Guthrum did several important
things first good throne was baptized
taking the name æthelstan with Alfred as
his adopted father secondly Alfred
accepted Danish occupation of these
lands whilst in return these lands were
considered Alfred's without ffred
notably gaining Western Mercia
incidentally the dividing line between
the Danish and Saxon parts of modern
dating that roughly follow an old Roman
Road could Watling Street having won a
major victory and secured a peace Alfred
began the task of securing his kingdom
from further Viking raids there were
three major ways he did this the first
was to reform the army
Alfred changed the way that troops were
raised so that only half of the leve
troops were active at any time this is
important because most soldiers were
taken from farms to fight meaning that
there were less people to grow in half
his crops
thus the army was smaller but more
efficient and importantly Wessex had a
standing army at all times meaning it
could respond to raids immediately that
Xchange was a naval builder which made
it harder for the Seabourn Vikings to
land on Wessex is long coastline the
final and arguably the most important
change that Alfred made was the creation
of a system of burrs which were
fortified towns there were roughly
thirty of these and they were manned by
the newly reformed army these burrs
acted as Garrison's and sanctuary in
case of Viking attack but they also grew
as important economic centers some burrs
such as Winchester were already
protected by Roman wolves and only
required Manning and repair others such
as Wallingford were built from scratch
each bow is assigned a number of height
which were measurements used to denote
the value of land it's a very complex
system and height does not represent a
certain amount of land but its value
land use for cattle would be worth more
heights than that used for growing wheat
for the defense of birds one man was
required from each hide also birds did
not have a standard size for example the
buret Winchester required 2,400 men for
its defense whereas the one at
Southampton only required 150 the
details of the system come from a
document could the burgle hide it which
indicates that in order to man all of
the birds across Wessex 27,000 men were
required which is an impressive amount
Alfred did not just oversee the
innovations in the army he was also
responsible for great changes in the
nature and appearance of kingship for
example Alfred began to brand himself is
not simply the king of Wessex but as the
king of the Saxons thus making him King
- even those who lived under the Vikings
to secure mercy and compliance Alfred
married his daughter Ethel fled to the
Lord of Mercy at Ethelred but
importantly Mercia did still have some
autonomy Alfred did show good faith to
the merchants when he captured London in
886 and instead of incorporating it into
Wessex he handed it over to Mercy Mercy
ins had little reason to rebel against
Alfred for two reasons the first was the
alfred was known for being a just king
and the second was thereby a lying
themselves with Wessex they had better
protection from Viking incursions one
consequence of Viking raiding and
invasion was the destruction of
monasteries which in turn had a major
effect on learning and education major
monasteries such as monk worm of cherry
Linda's farm and Iona had all been
sacked by Vikings many learned men were
killed their libraries burned in their
wealth transported back to Scandinavia
this led to what Alfred described as a
sharp downturn in learning which he
sought to correct to do this he began
inviting some of the most learned men
across the kingdom to his court to help
it is likely that Alfred was
exaggerating just how bad learning had
become since many of his new advisors
were from Murcia for example Pegman who
would later become the Archbishop of
Canterbury at least three others were
mercy as some were from foreign kingdoms
- such as grim bald a Frankish monk and
a sir a Welsh monk and the most famous
of Alfred's court intellectuals this
revival of learning is often called the
afridi and Renaissance and unlike the
Carolingian Renaissance under
Charlemagne Alfred was personally
involved in the production of some of
his literature much of this Renaissance
was centered around language
specifically when a person should use
Latin or use English it was decided that
most people should learn to read him
write in English with only the clergy
needing to study Latin Alfred was
himself learning Latin during the period
of
with the biking's and he used his
newfound knowledge to translate some
works into English
Alfred sums up his reasoning for
translating documents into English as
such it seems better to me that we
should turn into language that we can
all understand some books which may be
most necessary for all men to know he
was referencing religious works which
would teach good morals to his subjects
it's important to remember that many saw
the Viking invasions is the punishment
by God for bad behavior and to Alfred
reinvigorating learning was one way to
counter this a quick sidenote on
language one aspect of anglo-saxon
culture which differentiates it from its
continental European contemporaries is
the prevalence at the vernacular
language that is Old English and its use
instead of Latin other kingdoms such as
Frankie had their own vernacular
languages but things like law codes and
treaties were always written in Latin
whereas in anglo-saxon England a
significant number were written in Old
English one such document was Alfred's
law code produced sometime in the latter
half of his reign Alfred interestingly
begins his law code demanding that all
men keep the offside made which may
imply that this has been an issue the
our freedom Renaissance did not just
copy old works but also sort the
creation of new ones
the first was asses life of Alfred which
was probably a propaganda piece designed
for distribution to the Welsh is vitally
important for understanding Alfred as a
person another document that was most
likely created around this time was the
anglo-saxon Chronicle which is
essentially an annual list of major
events the anglo-saxon Chronicle was
kept and updated for many years and the
version of The Chronicle found at Medes
Hampstead modern day Peterborough was
updated well into the 12th century The
Chronicle alongside beads ecclesiastical
history are by far the two most
important sources for anglo-saxon
England and without them very little
would be known about the years between
the Roman withdrawal and the Norman
Conquest Wessex wouldn't be at peace
forever and sure enough it wasn't in 892
another great army landed in Wessex
thanks to the new system of burrs the
Vikings were not able to get anywhere
near as far inland as they had in the
870's
unfortunately for Murcia they had few
burrs and so the Vikings marched through
their territorial eventually into Wales
which at this point was still divided
into smaller kingdoms most or all of
whom had pledged their allegiance to
Alfred this was the last major Danish
incursion into the territory of Wessex
before Alfred's death in 899 Alfred had
thus managed to turn Wessex from a
kingdom struggling to resist the Vikings
to the sole anglo-saxon power it was on
top of the foundations built by Alfred
that the royal house of Wessex would go
on to be the first royal
of england alfred saw himself as the
architect of an england but be aware
that this was never realized in his
lifetime the northern half of
Northumbria still remained a nominally
independent anglo-saxon kingdom and the
continued obedience of Mercia was no
sure thing nowadays alfred occupies a
place in the english national psyche is
the founder of the nation of course most
of the information which survives from
his reign was written in his court by
his intellectuals and so his reputation
should be taken with the grain of salt
irrespective of all of this his
achievement certainly pushed Wessex in
the direction that made sure that this
land would ultimately be English and not
Scandinavian were often told to avoid
great man history where possible but in
the case of Alfred it's difficult to
strip them of this title and it's worth
remembering that of all the kings of
this land he's the only one to have ever
been the great I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching books
are in the description below and feel
free to subscribe if you want
you